When in Korea, it's best to have
a guide who really knows the country.
Fortunately, I have such a friend.
Steven Yeun, we've been naked together,
and as close as two men can be.
Yeah.
I'm excited to show you the country.
Maybe...
(speaking in Korean)
(audience laughs)
They're thrilled we're here, just thrilled.
Let's go.
(Korean instrumental music)
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
(yelling)
Nooo!
No!
Hold on.
No, why did it do that?
It let it go on purpose.
Hold on, we got another one.
Why?
Come on, come on.
No!
(thumping)
Yeah!
(audience cheering)
Yaaay.
I am now about to enjoy a traditional Korean meal.
Steven, can you tell me what these dishes are?
Um, yes.
You don't seem to know.
Do you know what this is?
What's that for example?
I mean, I've seen it, that's uh...
Seriously, you have no idea?
So it looks like rice.
Yeah?
(uncertain groan)
You're my cultural ambassador.
What are you doing?
I just eat it.
No, listen I'm Irish--
That's potato salad.
Yes, I know potato salad.
Yeah, that's good.
This was a Jewish delicatessen about 15 minutes ago.
Those look like pancakes of some kind.
Yes, yes, Korean pancakes, pajeon.
Pajeon?
Yup, has whatever my mom puts in it, I dunno.
I just eat it.
And then that is...
Fish cakes?
Why'd your voice get so high?
Uncertainty.
(laughter)
Is this a soup?
This is kimchi gungmul, or byul kimchi,
or one of those things,
which is essentially kimchi water.
Right.
You're sort of like Anthony Bourdain,
if he knew absolutely nothing.
This is you.
I believe this a spoon of some?
Maybe a spoon, maybe a fork?
It could be a knife?
Okay, let's not talk about the food you know nothing about.
We will eat the food he knows nothing about.
Try like this.
Oh, with spoon.
No that's...
not how you use...
Don't I have to use...
No, you can use your hand.
This is counter-intuitive to most...
You sort of...
(slurping)
(audience cheering)
You lose, I win.
Our ways are different,
but who's to say which one is better?
Me.
Yeah, that's a better way.